hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be delving
into the tragic but also noble and
honorable life
of the legendary flame hashira kyojuro
rengoku from his difficult childhood
which included the premature death of
his mother
and a strained relationship with his
father to his
tenure as the mighty flame hashira
rengoku left a massive impact on the
lives of our heroes
especially tanjiro and as i will explain
rengoku's legacy continued to shape the
story of demon slayer
all the way up to its final conclusion
so
let's all set our hearts ablaze as we
pay tribute
to this legendary warrior if you enjoy
the demon slayer content on this channel
and you want to see
more leave a like and comment it only
takes a second but it helps
a lot and if you're new to anime on pro
or maybe you watch
our videos but you haven't subscribed
yet make this the video that you
subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications finally this video
will contain
demon slayer manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution
you have been warned when we first meet
him in the story
rangoku is serving as the flame hashira
of the demon slayer core
he is the son of the former flame
hashira and he takes great pride
in his duties as one of the strongest
demon slayers
rengoku is full of energy and enthusiasm
and he is an incredibly skilled
swordsman due to his unwavering
commitment
to training and discipline rengoku is
also an
honorable and pure-hearted warrior who
abides by a strict
moral code he lives by the principle
that the strong have a duty to protect
the weak and in the spirit of that
principle
he has sworn to protect the human race
from the demons
because rengoku takes his duties very
seriously
and because he has great respect for the
rules of the demon slayer core
when he initially meets tanjiro and
nezuko he believes that killing nezuko
is the only option the fact that tanjiro
a demon slayer was protecting a demon
is a violation of every rule in the
demon slayer core
and since rengoku has personally
witnessed multiple demons committing
horrible murders of innocent people and
of his own comrades
he does not think that there is any need
for a trial here
what tanjiro did is a clear violation of
the demon slayer code
and so nezuko should be killed and
tanjiro should be punished
remember this initial first impression
that we got of rengoku and remember his
stance on nezuko because we will come
back to it later
now even though rengoku is the son of
the former flame hashira
his father shinjuro has been anything
but
supportive throughout his childhood
rengoku's father constantly told him
that he had no talent and that he would
never become
the next flame hashira rengoku's father
also drank frequently and he could be
downright abusive to his two
sons although rangoku's mother was a
much gentler person than his father
she sadly died when rangaku was still
quite young
so to say that rangoku had a tough and
tragic childhood
would be an understatement but despite
all of that
rengoku refused to give up on his dream
of becoming the flame hashira
and protecting the innocent even though
rengoku agreed with his father that he
didn't have any special
natural talents he still forced himself
to train hard and become strong
against all odds even though his father
kept telling him to just
quit and focus on becoming something
other than a hashira
rengoku refused to listen to his father
and as we know
he did eventually become the new flame
hashira
rengoku clearly did not inherit his
father's personality
because he was always very kind and
supportive to his younger brother
sanjuru not only did rengoku refuse to
allow his father's constant criticism to
bring him down
but he also did his best to bring other
people
up including his younger brother as a
result
senjuru looked up to his older brother
and saw him as an important source of
inspiration
in his own life since senjuru also had
to deal with his father's abuse and
criticism
the fact that he could count on his
older brother's support meant a great
deal to him
before she died rengoku's mother told
him that
as someone who is strong rengoku has a
duty to protect
those who are weaker than him and so
rengoku committed himself to saving
innocent people from the terror
of the demons in a special one-shot
manga chapter that came out
after the main demon slayer manga ended
we got to see what happened
during rengoku's very first mission as a
demon slayer
before he ever became a hashira this
early chapter of rengoku's life
is very important for understanding his
character
when he is dispatched on his first
mission
rengoku encounters a flute demon who by
that point had already murdered
nine of rengoku's demon slayer comrades
he had
also murdered a group of children and he
was about to murder
another child when rengoku arrived faced
with the sight of
all of those corpses rengoku was forced
to accept the tragic reality
about how fragile human life is and how
cruel and ruthless the demons can be
the flute demon is clearly a merciless
monster
and he has a powerful blood demon art
which makes him almost impossible to
fight
anyone who hears the sound of the
demon's flute has their entire nervous
system
thrown out of whack so it is impossible
to move and fight
properly while hearing the sound of the
demon's flute
one option for rengoku is to cover both
of his ears with his hands
but if he does that then he can't use
his sword and if he doesn't use a sword
then he can't defeat the demon
so rengoku is backed into a corner if he
uses his sword
his nervous system will be disrupted and
he won't be able to fight
but if he keeps his ears covered he
still won't be able to fight because he
will be defenseless
against the demon and if that wasn't bad
enough
the demon is able to use his flute to
summon deadly
wolves and these wolves are going to
devour rengoku if he doesn't find some
way to fight back
the demon thinks that all of this is
quite hilarious
all of those years of demon slayer
training have been rendered completely
useless
by the effect of his flute the demon
slayers are seemingly
powerless against him but rengoku then
proceeds to do something
extremely badass and something that the
flute demon
wasn't expecting rengoku hits his own
ears
so hard that he ruptures his own
eardrums
this temporarily disrupts his ability to
hear
which allows him to use his sword to
take the demon down
rengoku kills the demon and he saves the
innocent child that the demon was about
to murder
and then after all of that rengoku
smiles he actually smiles through the
pain
because he wants to reassure the
surviving child that everything is going
to be okay
rengoku then expresses gratitude to all
of his fallen comrades
it turns out that as they died the other
demon slayers used
sign language to secretly reveal the
nature of the flute demon's power to
rengoku
when rengoku arrived and saw the bodies
of his comrades
he saw the message that they were trying
to convey and
that is how he was able to figure out an
effective strategy for taking down the
flute
demon rengoku vows to one day become
admirable
just like his fallen comrades this
moment
and rengoku's behavior throughout this
entire mission
showcases so perfectly what kind of
valiant warrior he is
he thinks outside the box he sacrifices
his own body
in order to save the innocent and he is
able to smile through the pain
for the sake of others rengoku was
clearly living up to the promise that he
had made to his mother
the promise to do everything to protect
those who were weaker than him
and while this first mission does a lot
to show us what kind of person rengoku
is
this mission also shows us why renkoku
hated the demons
as much as he did and why he initially
wanted to just kill nezuko kamado
without any sort of trial or appeal
process
in his career as a demon slayer rengoku
faced demons who were brutal
and ruthless demons who laughed as they
killed his comrades
and even as they devoured innocent
children so
based on his own horrifying experiences
rengoku felt that no mercy can be shown
to these creatures after what he had
seen
he simply could not trust a demon he
believed that demons were
all inherently cruel and evil and so
they had to be killed
immediately before they have a chance to
harm
more innocent people but this would all
change during the mugen train arc
in the present rengoku is tasked with
riding a train that has become a regular
target for a particularly powerful demon
several demon slayers who had been sent
to investigate the train were never
heard from again
so on this particular mission rengoku
will be backed up
by some of the lower ranked demon
players including tanjiro
zenitsu inosuke and of course nezuko
after getting their tickets checked by
the conductor
rengoku tanjiro zenitsu and inosuke all
fall asleep and once that happens they
become targets for the mysterious demon
called
animu a demon with the ability to
infiltrate and manipulate
the dreams of his victims enmu sends a
human
into each of their dreams and he offers
to give these depressed humans
wonderful dreams in the future if they
destroy the spiritual cores of each
demon slayer inside their dream if these
spiritual cores are destroyed the demon
slayers will never be able to wake up
again
but when the girl who enters rengoku's
dream attempts to break his
fiery spiritual core a still unconscious
rengoku
instinctively grabs the girl by the neck
in the real world
that is how honed his fighting instincts
are
and this is how determined rengoku is to
keep fighting to protect the innocent
his demon slayer instincts are so well
trained that he is able to unconsciously
identify a threat
and neutralize it while still asleep it
doesn't get much more badass than that
when nezuko eventually uses her blood
demon art to wake
everyone up rangoku tells tanjiro that
he will defend the eight
train cars from enmu together with
nezuko and zenitsu
while tanjiro and inosuke go to the
front of the train to confront
enmu rengoku once again shows off what
an absolute legend he is
as he defends the back five cars all on
his own
leaving zenitsu and nezuko to take care
of just the front
three cars this makes perfect sense for
rengoku
because as a hashira he feels obligated
to handle most of the burden
on his own and his ability to protect 5
cars by himself
is a testament to his incredible speed
strength
and determination and in the end the
demon slayers managed to save
hundreds of innocent lives on the mugen
train something that would have been
impossible without
rengoku's extraordinary commitment after
tanjiro and inosuke managed to defeat
enemy upper moon 3 akaza makes his
appearance
and he attempts to kill tanjiro at this
point tanjiro is already injured as a
result of his fight with enmu
sorenguku steps up to protect tanjiro
and he takes
akaza head on akaza is very impressed
with rengoku's swordsmanship skills
and he invites rangoku to become a demon
like him
but rengoku instantly refuses he has
dedicated his life
to fighting demons and he has no
interest in becoming one of them and yet
akaza keeps trying to convince him to
become a demon after all
if rengoku turns into a demon then he
won't have to worry about death
and he can spend all of eternity
training to get stronger
akasa would love this because he loves
to fight strong opponents
and since rangoku is already strong even
as a human
he would have incredible potential if he
were to become a demon
akasa can't understand why anyone would
want to remain a weak human who is
doomed to lead a short life
and then die instead of becoming an
overpowered demon
who can live forever but rengoku says
that death
is the very thing that makes human life
so precious
and beautiful as rengoku puts it growing
old
and dying is what gives meaning and
beauty to the fleeting span of a human
life
it's precisely because we age and die
that our lives have value
and nobility akasa still doesn't get it
and he thinks that it would be a waste
for a gifted swordsman like rengoku to
die
so soon but rengoku doesn't think that
death is sad at all
death is only natural for human beings
and so whenever it may come
it is not to be feared rather death is a
perfectly normal part of life
at this point tanjiro attempts to help
rangoku in the fight against
akaza however rengoku tells tanjiro to
stay put
because he was already injured during
the fight with enmu and if his
wound reopens he will probably die
rengoku then proceeds to engage akuza in
combat
yet again and his skill and
determination truly impress
akaza eventually akaza manages to give
rengoku
a fatal wound by sticking his entire arm
through the hashida's stomach akaza then
tries to convince rengoku one last time
to become a demon if he doesn't decide
to become a demon now
he will definitely die from this wound
becoming a demon
is his only chance to save himself but
instead of entertaining akaza's proposal
rengoku decides to keep fighting against
akaza
despite this severe injury in fact
rengoku uses the wound
to his advantage the sun is about to
rise
and rengoku's plan is to keep akaza
right where he is
by keeping akaza's arm trapped inside
his
own stomach then once the sun rises and
makes contact with
akaza the demon will burn up and die
yes rengoku's wound will surely kill him
but he intends to do his duty as a
hashida one last time
by taking akaza down with him up to this
point
akaza was just impressed with rangoku's
strength and determination
but now akasa begins to really fear for
his own life
he does his best to break free from
rangoku's grip
but the hashira refuses to budge once
again he fights through the pain
just so he can fulfill his duty as
hashira now desperate
akaza cuts his own arms off in order to
escape from rengoku's grip
as rengoku drops down to his knees akaza
runs away
into the forest before the sun can reach
him
that is when we get an incredibly
emotional moment in which
tanjiro heartbroken about what just
happened to rengoku
throws his sword at the fleeing akaza
and screams at him to stop running away
like a coward tanjiro says that rengoku
is braver and more honorable than akaza
will ever be
because he fought to save the lives of
others until the very end and he didn't
run away like a coward
tanjiro says that rangoku won this fight
because even though akaza is alive and
rengoku is dying
akaza is running away while rengoku
stood his ground
and fought with honor until his very
last
breath and i have to agree with tanjiro
here
akasa as a demon is objectively stronger
than rengoku but even though rengoku was
fatally injured
he nearly killed akaza by forcing him to
face the sunlight
and in the end akaza ran away from the
fight
so akaza lost and rengoku won even
though this would sadly be
rengoku's final victory as he is dying
rengoku does not show fear or sadness
he stays true to his convictions until
the very end
and he even takes time to tell tanjiro
to visit the rengoku family home so that
he can learn more about the dance of the
fire god
he also asks tanjiro to tell his younger
brother to follow his own path
and to tell his father to take care of
himself just
think about that for a second even as he
is dying rangoku wants to help tanjiro
in his quest to learn more about the
dance of the fire god
and he also wants to encourage his
brother one last time
while sending kind words to his father
the same father who mistreated him and
discouraged him for his entire life
that is the kind of person that rengoku
is
he is always doing his best to help
others and he doesn't hold
any sort of grudge against his father in
fact
rengoku believes that his father acted
the way that he did because he was
worried about losing his two
sons rengoku's father knew from his own
experience as a former hashira
that being a demon slayer is extremely
dangerous
but because he is old-fashioned and
doesn't know how to show his true
emotions
he tried to discourage his sons from
putting themselves in danger
by telling them to just give up on
becoming demon slayers because they're
not
good enough he treated them this way not
because he hated them
but because he loved them and didn't
want to lose them
at least that is how rengoku interprets
it and again
i am in awe of the strength of this
man's character
most people would hate their father if
they were in rangoku's shoes
but rangoku is not most people
he is able to see the best in everyone
including his father
rengoku then looks tanjiro right in the
eye and says that after seeing how
nezuko was fighting to protect innocent
people
on board the train he now accepts her as
a member
of the demon slayer core that is a
complete reversal from his previous
stance
that all demons should be killed
immediately and that anyone who
cooperates with them should be punished
but this drastic change shows us that
rengoku is the kind of person who is
open to learning new things
and to changing his mind he is not
stubborn and stuck in his ways like so
many people
instead he is willing to learn from new
experiences and develop as a person
which is such an important quality for
anyone to have and so
after seeing nezuko risking her life to
protect humans from a fellow demon
rengoku understands that nezuko is
different and that she deserves
respect rengoku then tells tanjiro
zenitsu and inosuke that he believes in
them
as the next generation of hashira he
then tells them not to feel bad about
him dying
because as a hashira it is his duty to
give his own life to protect them
just as his comrades gave their lives to
protect him
during his very first mission rengoku
leaves tanjiro with
these words go ahead and live with your
head
held high no matter how devastated you
may be by your own weakness or
uselessness
set your heart ablaze grit your teeth
and look straight ahead wow
this was so powerful and it reminds me
of my favorite anime character of all
time
kamina those of you who have seen guren
lagann know exactly what i'm talking
about
in his final moments rengoku sees a
vision of his mother
and he asks her whether he did a good
job in keeping the promise that he had
made to her
she tells him that he did a wonderful
job and as he is about to die
rengoku smiles earlier on rengoku said
that death
is not something to fear it is a
perfectly natural part of life
and in fact death is the very thing that
makes human life
so precious in the end rengoku stayed
true to his own philosophy
and to his principles and not only did
he willingly die to protect his comrades
but he died with a smile on his face
without
any fear or sadness and even though
rengoku died a noble death
at this relatively early point in the
story his legacy
definitely didn't die with him rengoku
sacrificed his life in order to save
tanjiro and tanjiro would eventually go
on to defeat
muzon without rengoku's sacrifice
tanjiro would have died here
and muzon would not have been defeated
but more than that
rengoku sacrifice inspired tanjiro
zenitsu inosuke
and many others and it drove them to
become the incredible demon slayers that
they would eventually become
so when you really think about it
despite being a side character who died
relatively early on rengoku ended up
playing a really important role
in the overall story and i'm so glad
that this was the case
because rengaku is both a great hashira
and
a wonderful human being and that is why
his legacy
still burns brightly like an eternal
flame
that will never be extinguished if you
guys enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
demon player content here on the channel
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help
and if you're new to anime opera or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you can
also hit me up on twitter
and instagram at animeopror
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma and red
haired raven
disciples of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata pate
heffa
algital dr cortman the toasted chi ray
carlo
emperor otaku spidey life tinel tungsten
tarkis
baked buddhist and cody hebert finally
thank you to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
angel cruz anatoly kazatsky cricket xp
very gucci alicia octor bonnie parks
kinokami and water
ted no ted isparky65 joyan garcia fat
boy games
metal mama corey mcgowan deadly saint
soul ray slice and dice and pilu
if you guys enjoy our videos and you
feel that they provide value to you
consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you